sitting here today how many FS does
Erica give about Lisa Vanderpump no
matter how you look at it it's been a
season of some so far on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
thanks - puppy gate are we finally done
with puppy gate I think so I think that
we move on and a cast member not showing
up after a certain time you know changes
the dynamic Vanderpump has walked away
from the group isn't showing up for
things but we know cameras continue to
follow her how do you feel about that
how do I feel about it I mean it's not
my show I love you how can you say you
love me all right she does I think she's
playing her own game which is kind of
what she's done the whole time so you
know who knows where it goes from there
she's got a bit rogue he was writing
blogs on our own website calling us pigs
calling you pigs yeah what do you make
of all that side of things
great good for you pigs are smarter than
dogs right it's a scientific fact
the reunion is probably the next time
any of you will see Vanderpump if she
chooses to show ya if she shows up yes
do you think she will I think it would
be she should show up and she should
tell her side of the story and she
should sit down with the rest of us and
talk about what happened what is that
gonna look like though because it's
usually the couches are divided in kind
of one group who faced off against the
other yeah I hope she's right in the
middle with all of us so that we can all
see each other and hear each other
equally
what do you think this group needs out
of her to move forward I think you know
an acknowledgment of her hand in the
whole puppy gate issue would help a lot
the acknowledgement of her involvement
whether directly or indirectly whether
you told someone directly or you
indirectly had someone do it just that
you did it sitting here today how many
FS does Erica give about Lisa Vanderpump
you know I I'm neutral it's neither good
nor bad for me it's nowhere what's the
big drama coming up cuz the first half
of the season has been focused all about
LVP where does the target turn in the
second well I think there's some
interesting dynamics with Camille and
the group and I think that's where
you're gonna see the majority of
conflicts Camille she has a strong
opinion about a lot of stuff that seems
to go against the strong opinions of
everyone else it seems to go against the
strong opinions of herself quite
honestly okay so some contradictions
there yes
[Music]
seems are going to see Denise find her
voice within this group well yes
Denise does I didn't use always had her
voice Denise played her her first season
very smartly and I feel that she sat
back and watched him inserted herself
when she needed to can you get to see
that unfold more and more that a lot
more where these contraptions you mean a
strap-on oh my god all right all this
fun that's coming up yeah told me the
trip to Provence gets a little uh Rose a
fuel how do you know this because Teddy
told me Teddy told you okay that maybe
she doesn't remember what happened in
Provence this is true some of us were
over-served and maybe yeah have a little
too much fun do you remember what
happened
yeah I was sober because I had a
migraine that day so thank you migraines
okay so you are like no no no yes that
was I was pretty clear give me a little
hint or tease of what the hijinks are
when everyone's over-served there's a
lot of unnecessary yelling and poking
and prodding and picking and sticking
and you know when you're when you're
drunk you talk that's what happens
talking about the group that is there
are people who aren't there both I think
thank you I think we touched about
everybody and then everybody turned on
each other yeah yeah we see in the
mid-season tease no
good is that that rose a fueled day yes
okay what leads not saying you'll see it
give me one word of how you power
antenna okay cuz you also say I kind of
feel like the two of you are in cahoots
you gotta find out whether in cahoots
about
okay so cahoots lisa rinna pushed me out
all one thought okay I want to sit and
marinate on oh you have to marinate on
that so now Erica is marinating on her
season 9 experience there's a whole you
know you can either walk away feeling
really defeated and sort of like down or
you can walk away feeling like you know
what I'm okay and I that's how I feel
I'm okay do you like this dynamic as it
is this group as it stands I had a lot
of fun with these girls this year I
really did and and I think that because
we were thrown such a curve that we as a
cast kind of gelled together in a way
that I have not the previous seasons
before and I think that that's something
this season you can see is that the five
of us really pulled together but you
know maybe I'm just hopeful that's good
things change I mean it could be you
know who knows what those other [ __ ]
are saying about me whatever I'm just
being nice
[Music]